today on the Matt Walsh show the
professed bigoted Nick Cannon has
helpfully demonstrated for all of us
what racism actually is and what it
sounds like
and also not only that but what form of
racism is still acceptable in society
there's only one form of racism left
that you're allowed to engage in we'll
talk about what that is also five
headlines including the heroic young boy
who rescued his sister from a dog attack
and paid the price for it physically we
can all learn a lot from this kid it's
an incredible story we'll talk about
that and in our daily cancellation we'll
discuss an article from the African
American History Museum's website which
says that among other things objectivity
politeness
and science are hallmarks of white
culture which sounds pretty white
supremacists to me not what you'd expect
to find on the African American History
Museum's website but we'll talk about
all that coming up but first we begin
here you know I'm not ready to move on
from this Jess yeah I know the media is
very ready
desperate to in fact move on but there's
something to be learned here so I want
to focus on it again now backing up just
for a moment of course it's it's it's
difficult to exactly decipher what Nick
Cannon is saying in his rambling racist
tirade against white people he appears
to for example think that melanin is
some sort of almost magical potion that
imbues compassion and and and virtue and
intelligence on people but the basic
points are clear canon believes that
white people are lesser they're savages
they're barbarians they're suffering
from a deficiency they lack compassion
they lack self-esteem they lack soul the
only way they can act as evil and more
in fact I guess we'll play for you if
you haven't seen it yet will go ahead
and play this clip just to refresh your
memory if you have seen it this is this
is what Nick Cannon has to say about
white people watch when we talk about
the power of Mellon 80 people when we
talk about who we really are as gods and
right and and that melanin is so power
and it connects us in a way that the
reason why they fear black the reason
why they fear is because they the lack
that they have of it so then when you
see what's you know doctor
Francis II wasn't talked about is that
fear in that that they violation see we
have a person that has has the lack of
pigment the lack of melon right that
they know that they will be annihilated
so therefore however they got the power
they they have the lack of compassion
and melanin comes with compassion
melanin comes with sold and we know we
call it soul weed so brothers and
sisters
that's the melanin that connects the
people that don't have it have are are
lit and I'm gonna say this carefully
yeah are a little less and and where the
term actually comes from cuz I'm
bringing it all the way back around okay
to Minister Farrakhan to where they may
not have the compassion or the the when
they were sent to the mountains of
Caucasus when they when they didn't have
the power of the Sun that was that the
Sun then started to deteriorate so then
they're acting out of fear they're
acting out of low self esteem they're
acting out of a deficiency so therefore
the only way that they can act is evil
the only way they can they have to rob
steal rape kill and fight like your in
order to survive exactly so then these
people who didn't have but we had and
when I say we I speak of the melon ated
people right they had to be savages they
had to be barbaric they had because
they're in these Nordic mountains
they're in these rough torrential
environments so they they're acting as
animals right so they're the ones that
are actually closer to animals they're
the ones that are actually the true
savages okay much to say here but before
we do I want to tell you about our
friends over at LifeLock you know I I
think all of us at least a time or two
have may become close hope may be we
actually may be not just close but have
actually been duped by internet scammers
because internet scammers are getting
more and more sophisticated in fact in
the five headlines we've got a story
about an internet scam that was running
yesterday talk about sophisticated
and that's coming up but the point is
these are turbulent times and fraudsters
just love it they love to take advantage
of the turbulence of the uncertainty
cybersecurity researchers are warning
that cyber criminals are sending emails
that include black lives matter in the
subject line in an effort to install
malware on victims computers so
whatever's going on in the news whatever
people are talking about they're gonna
find a way to take advantage of that
just to scam people and that's why it's
so important to take preventative
measure every day we put our information
at risk on the Internet you could miss
certain identity threats just by you
know if you just try to monitor your
credit or whatever yeah you're gonna see
that but you're gonna there's a lot that
you're gonna miss good thing there's
life luck life lock detects a wide range
of identity threats like your social
security number being on sale for the
dark web stuff like that you're not
gonna be able to find for yourself and
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised
they're gonna send you an alert
immediately and they're gonna help you
sort it out from there no one can
prevent all identity theft or monitor
all transactions at all businesses but
life lock can see threats that you might
miss on your own join now and save up to
25% off your first year go to life lock
calm slash Walsh that's life lock calm
slash Walsh for 25% off now back to that
Nick Cannon Club whatever else we could
say about about it and about Cannon we
should be grateful in some ways that
Cannon has performed the valuable
service of demonstrating what racism
actually sounds like what it is because
the word is misused and abused and
misapplied so often that you can it can
be easy to forget that it's a real thing
especially with the left
having made racist the term racist
interchangeable with has opinions that
differ from my own 99% of the time when
someone on the Left is using the term
that's what they actually mean but
that's obviously not what racism
actually is racism is the belief that a
certain race of people are lesser savage
barbarian deficient which is verbatim
what Nick Cannon said about white people
so if your child ever asks you what
racism is well you could say here
sweetie
I'll show you what it is and then play
the Nick Cannon video for them and that
will that will clear it up of course
this all this goes without saying but if
a white celebrity or white non-celebrity
said what well forget about it if a
white person said used any one of those
terms that canon used about white people
if a white person used it in relation to
black people you take just just take any
five second snippet from that two-minute
clip and if that was and and and you put
that into the mouth of a white person
well they're going to be condemned by
everyone all parties all corners
everywhere in America they would
immediately lose every job they have in
every job they might have had in the
future and this would all happen with
lightning speed there would be no one
except maybe on the fringes of the
fringe of the fringe speaking up in
defense of him
that's because contrary to claims of
systemic racism and inherent racism in
American culture anti black racism is
not only rejected by the mainstream but
it is probably the most it is the view
that is most rejected by the mainstream
m''d be difficult to think of anything
that is more rejected in mainstream
culture than anti black racism and not
just by the mainstream it's rejected
almost everywhere in the mainstream in
America in the mainstream and in in most
of its tributaries and that's a good
thing
it's a sign of progress doesn't mean
that anti black racism doesn't exist it
just means that anti black racism has a
very difficult time finding safe harbor
and and and a sounding board and a
cheering section this is not the case
for anti-white racism which is often
ignored or tacitly approved or outright
defended and we've seen all three of
these happen with the Nick Cannon story
which is why it's so instructive and
worth work worth focusing on Viacom CBS
of course terminated their their
relationship with with the bigoted Nick
Cannon which is a pretty severe
financial penalty to be sure but you
know and and of course but I also say
that attendance
because he wouldn't surprise me at all
if they hire him back next week or even
tomorrow so we'll see how long this
sticks but the corporation very
conspicuously avoided denouncing canons
anti-white racism in their statement on
why they were firing him you would think
that that would be the reason they fired
him but it's not their official reason
for firing him has nothing to do with
calling white people savage barbarians
instead they were focused on comments
that cannon made calling black people
the true Hebrews and claiming that
blacks can't be anti-semitic because
they're the real Semitic people now this
is false it's bizarre it's objectionable
but it's it's tame in comparison with
essentially claiming that the white race
is subhuman which is what Nick Cannon
said there okay Viacom CBS ignored that
part of it which seems to suggest that
if cannon hadn't mentioned Jewish people
if he had just skipped over that part
and it stuck too dehumanizing the entire
white race instead he'd still have a job
today now most of the media coverage we
talk about the reaction to this most of
the media coverage has followed Viacom's
lead choosing to pretend that one of the
country's most famous and ubiquitous
celebrities didn't just claim that a
whole race of people is comprised of
evil savages there's a in an article in
the on the website essence that
summarizes the racist diatribe of Nick
Cannon as a conversation about quote
violence at the hands of white people
and then there are other articles a lot
of them that basically try to paint
Cannon as the aggrieved party talking
about how he's you know demanding
ownership of his shows on Viacom and
making no mention again of his
explicitly racist attack against whites
this has been the general strategy from
most corners just pretend that he didn't
say it at all that's the strategy
pretend this is an anti semitism
controversy
fact Nick Cannon after initially being
defiant about it and even saying that
he's the one owed an apology finally
backed down while I say finally it took
him 12 hours and he backed down and he
issued the the inevitable groveling
apology last night but he doesn't
apologize at all in his apology he
doesn't apologize at all for calling
white people savage barbarians he like
everybody else is pretending that that
didn't happen and instead his statement
I'll read some of it to you his
statement or probably his PR team
statement says first and foremost I
extend my deepest and most sincere
apologies to my Jewish brothers and
sisters for the hurtful and divisive
words that came out of my mouth during
my interview with Richard Griffin they
enforced the worst stereotypes of a
proud of magnificent people and I feel
shamed of the uninformed a naive place
that these words came from the video of
this interview has since been removed
while the Jewish experience encompasses
more than 5,000 years and there's so
much I've yet to learn I have it at
least a minor history lesson over the
past few days and to say that it is
eye-opening would be a very vast that
would be a vast understatement I want to
express my gratitude to the rabbi's
community leaders and institutions who
reached out to me to enlighten me
instead of chastising me I want to
assure my Jewish friends new and old
that this is only the beginning of my
education I am committed to deeper
connections more profound learning and
strengthening the bond between the our
two cultures today and every day going
forward ok great that covers the
anti-semitic portion what about calling
all of your white fans evil savage soul
as subhuman barbarians what about that
part that doesn't matter apparently
we're not going to talk about that so
this is all ignoring and tastic Allah
accepts tacitly accepting anti-white
racism that's what that looks like but
as I said there's always plenty of
people who are ready to outright defend
it so you could have gone yesterday
especially to Nick Cannon's Twitter or
his Facebook and you could have found
hundreds probably thousands of people
expressing their support for him
many of whom explicitly endorsing his
racist comments and I know that we like
to say when we see this kind of stuff on
Twitter or Facebook we like to say
that's not the real world it's just
Twitter or face
but it's the internet now it's the real
world world the internet exists in the
real world it's not the matrix this is
the real world it's a communication
mechanism it's communication tool that
real people use and so if you see
thousands of people on the internet
saying to Nick Cannon I agree with what
you said about white people what does
that mean it means that there are
thousands of people that agree the fact
that they're expressing it on the
internet doesn't make it any less real
which is the dumbest I've talked about
this before kind of a side note but this
I guess it's wishful thinking but I find
it so stupid that you hear all the time
this this distinction people want to
make between the real world and the
Internet these are human beings who are
expressing how they feel and what they
really think that is I hate to tell you
that's real and so if you go to the
Internet and you happen to notice wow
there are a lot of scumbags here I'm
sorry to say that means there are a lot
of scumbags in reality those scumbags
they don't just materialize on the
internet and they're not all bots either
most of them totally real and and and
and and not only that but what that
tells us is is probably the internet
gives us the most accurate insight into
how people actually are yes if you bump
into them at the supermarket they're
gonna be polite to you face to face but
if you want to know what they actually
feel like and what they actually think
wait until they're hiding behind a
keyboard and especially behind anonymous
accounts and then you get an idea of who
these people really are and that's the
case on the Internet in general penny
wait that's a justice I know in in in in
in this case you go to the internet you
go to social media and you see about
many many comments and support and what
that means again is that there are many
many people who support MIT Kansas in
not just not just anonymous people on
the internet either there have been you
know some of the defenders are some of
the most powerful forces and media like
Sean Diddy Combs
offered the racist Nick Cannon a job and
express solidarity with him saying we
are for our people first that's what he
tweeted famous athletes have gotten it
on the action Dwyane Wade deleted it but
originally he tweeted something saying
praising canons leadership and saying we
are with you the normalization of
anti-white racism which is what this is
does have consequences real-world
consequences as I've documented the PACU
mented in the past and talked about in
the past there have been a slew of
brutally violent attacks against white
people in recent weeks and though none
of them have been prosecuted as hate
crimes even though doing something like
pouring paint on a BLM mural apparently
is a hate crime in spite of that it's
difficult to believe that there's no
racial motivation to any of these
assaults because what else can we expect
when a certain demographic is constantly
portrayed as the villain and all the
evil in the world is blamed on them and
hatred and degradation of this group is
is ignored or outright justified we
can't be surprised to see this carefully
cultivated resentment and suspicions
spilling over into violence and worse
it's a story as old as humanity we've
seen it play out countless times and now
the cycle is beginning again we have to
realize there are other consequences too
because racism is indeed a cycle it
feeds off itself racism from one group
towards another fuels racism from the
targeted group back in the other
direction and on and on round and round
again and again and again it's a story
of humanity and perhaps it's inevitable
but if we can see the cycle playing out
and recognize it we should try to do our
best to break out of it so when you make
a group of people into the villain when
you heap scorn on them when you insist
that they should feel nothing but guilt
and shame and so on along with
encouraging hatred of
that group from the outside you also
encourage hatred within and from that
group you are fueling the cycle of
resentment and hatred you are
essentially trying to provoke the hated
group into acting exactly as you claim
they act into living down to your
expectations so perfectly example this
this which we've discussed many times
this relentless parade of hate crime
hoaxes that we see all the time people
constantly pretending that they got
racist notes left on their car or they
found a noose or whatever it is
eventually some white guy is really
gonna go and leave a racist note on a
car or plant a noose or something
eventually it's gonna happen for real
now for the past 20 years it's it's most
of the time been a hoax but eventually
it will happen for real and when it does
happen the media of course will pretend
at the past 20 years of non-stop hoaxes
didn't happen or had nothing to do with
it I mean it's almost like you know if I
didn't know any better I might say that
the media and other forces in America
are trying to provoke this it's almost
like they're trying to stir racial
tension racial discord almost as if they
want a race war because it's good for
ratings
and it's useful to their ideological
goals most of all yes almost it's almost
like that or you know exactly like that
now we're gonna move on to our headlines
but before we do you know talking about
all this news everything going on in
society good time to mention that Ben
Shapiro has a new book coming out called
how to destroy America in three easy
steps and it's about as relevant and
current as a book can get this goes on
sale Tuesday July 21st at 6 p.m. Eastern
3 p.m. Pacific and Ben will be doing a
virtual live signing event on the day of
release with your purchase of a signed
copy you can write in a question which
may be read and answer as he signs the
books live on air you
order your sign copy and write in your
question at daily wire.com slash been
what the book talks about it covers two
fundamentally different visions of
America that are now on the table one
vision is unifying you know it finds our
unity and shared philosophy ideas
culture history the other disintegrates
our culture in the name of fundamental
change how to destroy America 3 easy
steps gets into all of that it details
how this other worldview has gained so
much cultural ground so quickly very
important again that's daily wire.com
slash Ben order your sign copy and join
Ben's live signing on Tuesday July 21st
okay number one a major hacking incident
at Twitter the accounts of Bill Gates
Elon Musk Apple bunch of other accounts
as well they're very high profile
accounts were hacked and tweets were
posted by the hackers soliciting people
to send money or Bitcoin and in exchange
gates and musk whoever would send back
money so I think that I think the Bill
Gates one said something like send me a
thousand dollars and I'll send you back
two thousand and it seems that a large
number of people depressingly though not
shockingly we're dumb enough to actually
do it well gee this seems totally
legitimate and valid does it I think I
think it's Bill Gates is asking me to
send a thousand dollars we'll give me
two thousand it sounds good to me I'll
go ahead and send them a thousand
dollars it turns out that the hackers
may have gained access through the
backdoor essentially they somehow got
access to Twitter's control panel and it
looks like a Twitter employee gave them
access either I don't know why maybe it
was paid off blackmailed who knows and
from there they could do whatever they
wanted they could hack anyone they could
access any account which probably means
that a great many high-profile accounts
were compromised and I guess if you're a
high profile account and you have
sensitive DMS that you send via Twitter
well get your get your PR team ready now
because they're gonna have a lot of work
cut out for them which is which is just
one of the reasons why you know
sending sensitive messages through
something like Twitter he's an extremely
stupid thing to do I even though they're
supposedly private general rule here if
there's if there's a I think a good
general rule even if you're not high
profile never send a message through
Twitter or Facebook that you definitely
wouldn't want everyone in the world to
see even though it's supposedly not
public just a good good good strategy if
there's if there's something you want to
say or communicate that you don't want
the whole world to see find a different
way to communicate it may be carrier
pigeon would be more secure than Twitter
dm's okay number two Bridger Walker a
six year old boy has gone viral I've
gotten a lot of attention deserved
attention for once good to see someone
getting deserved attention positive
attention after he stepped in between
his little sister and a charging dog the
dog mauled him in the face
and the gruesome stuff latched onto his
cheek but the boy doesn't seem to regret
defending his sister he says that if
someone had to die he thought that it
should be him not his sister that's what
he said and remarkable courage and
heroism from from this this little guy
there he is with his injuries and you
know something it looks grisly I can't
imagine the pain that this child was in
and probably still in but I'm hopeful
and I feel pretty good I'm optimistic
that you look at that
it's a young kid kids bodies heal very
quickly from injuries I've seen that
from my own children even though thank
God they never sustained an injury that
gruesome or anywhere near to that but
even so you know children are very
resilient physically so the hope is I
would of course hope and pray that those
injuries heal and and maybe leaving just
enough of a scar for people to see for
the rest of his life what a badass he is
and he'll have a hell of an amazing
story to tell that's my hope anyway
but regardless heroic little guy amazing
story inspiring story
there's also an infuriating aspect of
this story which is the irresponsible
a-hole dog owners who kept an aggressive
dangerous dog around there's that too I
am just I think I hope we all are just
tired of seeing stories of children
being mauled by these dogs and it's
always the same breeds right pitbull
German Shepherd a couple others this was
a German Shepherd no surprise you see a
headline like this child mauled by a dog
you've got two or three dog breeds in
mind before you even click on it you
know it's gonna be one of those and
every single time it is always the same
breeds but people keep them around
because what they're cute I guess
yeah I mean they're they're animals
they're extremely aggressive by Nature
these are very big strong tough animals
that are made to Maul things and
killings but uh you know I'll keep it
around in a neighborhood with little
kids because it's so cute meanwhile
children are mold sometimes killed I'm
just sick of it I hope the dog was put
down I think the dog was put down thank
God if I were the father of that kid I'd
do it myself we wouldnt have to bring it
to the vet it would that would be an
immediate thing and hopefully the owners
go to prison for reckless endangerment
that's the other part of this you choose
to keep a dangerous dog around that dog
hurts or kills someone you should go to
jail for that in my mind number three a
Spirit Airlines flight to Philly from
Fort Lauderdale Lauderdale was delayed
which tends to happen sometimes when
you're flying more and more it seems
like but some of the passengers were not
very happy about the delayed flight and
here's how they reacted to the news
[Music]
so I'm not exactly sure what the
strategy is there have to be honest with
you beat up the airline staff and that
will make the boarding process faster
and you know you do know of course that
the people at the gate have nothing to
do with the flight being delayed which
is which is a misconception that a lot
of people seem to have you know I do a
lot of flying and I've never seen a
reaction quite like that but I have seen
plenty of times where people are getting
angry and annoyed at the gate agent
because the flights delayed talk about
talking about shooting the messenger is
they've got absolutely nothing to do
there's nothing they can do about it
it's totally not there it's as much
their fault as it is yours
so getting mad at them and and and
everything makes no sense especially
physically assaulting them I think makes
even less sense really you're upset
about the flight being delayed and
because you want to get where you're
going faster and but you react in a way
that now you're gonna be sitting in a
jail cell instead so that just seems it
seems counterproductive perhaps but at
least these people were arrested that's
the good news
arrested charged right away because you
know you can get away with that stuff
anywhere in America it seems like these
days except airports airports don't play
around and I'm guessing these girls
probably are looking at federal charges
too because you you do anything illegal
in an airport you're looking at local
charges federal charges to if they want
to do that
airports it seems are the one bastion of
law and order and civility left in
America and I never thought I would say
that in a positive way but but here we
are
I may just move to an airport you think
about airports okay airports are still
arresting criminals anarchists will be
arrested you can drink a cocktail at
7:00 a.m. and nobody judges you those
are two positives those are really the
only two positives but that's enough for
me these days number four the National
Association of police organizations
though it twice endorsed Obama Biden now
endorses Trump according to the Daily
wire Napo President Michael Mikhail's
letter announcing the endorsement noted
the quote unfair and inaccurate appro
appro briam there's a good word you
don't see it very often being directed
at our members by so many adding quote
we particularly value your directing the
Attorney General to aggressively
prosecute those who attack our officers
talking to Trump and so that this
shouldn't be a surprise every police
organization in existence you would
think would would be endorsing Trump /
Biden every police officer it's it's
crazy to think that there would be any
police officer anywhere in America that
would still be voting Democrat after
this you Democrats are validly
professedly anti a cop as far as
Democrats are concerned if you're police
officer and you defend yourself to
preserve your own life against the
violent criminal you should go to jail
and face capital punishment even that's
you don't get more anti-cop than that so
number five finally great news here the
last piece of the puzzle is in place
freedom is now reigning in America peace
and unity will soon follow a utopia all
of our problems are solved as the city
of Minneapolis is preparing to legalize
women going topless in parks this was a
very important issue especially in
Minneapolis because they got nothing
else to worry about right they only had
a half of their city burned down by
anarchists but we don't need to worry
about that let's focus on making sure
that women can go topless in parks
the Commissioner of the city park board
who is a dude by the way just have to
note that said I firmly believe the law
should treat people equally regardless
of gender in spaces where men are
allowed to go shirtless women and
transgender people should be able to as
well
inversely in spaces where we
inappropriate for women to expose their
chests it should be inappropriate for
men as well people should not be
discriminated against just because
heterosexual men have over sexualized
them any argument that can be made
against the exposure of a woman's chest
should apply just as strongly against
the exposure of a man's chest sure ok
there Chris the dude Chris wants women
topless in the park but for equality
sake you understand that's what this is
about
purely the principle of the matter
that's what he's standing up for in fact
all the men and local officials around
the country who have who have made this
change and you're seeing it more and
more in cities and states across the
country where they're they're you know
freeing the nipple but we should
remember it and very often its majority
men male leadership that are they're
passing these rules and ordinances and
laws but just remember they're doing it
for equality that's all this is about ok
no ulterior motives they just want to
make sure everything is free and equal
it will never cease to fascinate me that
feminists continue to try to destroy the
patriarchy by taking off their clothes
it's it is perhaps the most
counterproductive form of protest of all
time and that is saying something that
is saying quite a lot these days because
there are great many counterproductive
forms of protest that might take the
cake though and that's it for headlines
we're going to go to our daily
cancellation but first you know as we
were just saying a lot going on in the
world hard to even know where to start
and when you but but the thing is with
with so much news it's hard to know
where to go to get the real story and
I'll tell you what you have to do you
have to go outside of the narrative and
get the facts so if you're a political
junkie set on getting both sides of the
story get a readers past today from
daily wire calm you'll get access to
exclusive op-eds from us your podcast
host as well as guest writers
in-depth analysis from our great daily
wire reporters on top of our regular
breaking news
my latest article you can go if you get
a reader's pass you can read that and
it's about George the George Floyd
memorials listen we're tearing down
memorials of and monuments to dead men
who supposedly did bad things well
George Floyd did a at least one very bad
thing and what about that what about his
murals so I talked about that make that
case this membership tier is already a
bargain at three dollars a month but if
you joined today you get your first
month for 99 cents you also get access
to our mobile app or see push
notifications for breaking news special
content as well and you can join the
community of daily wire members who are
actively commenting and discussing our
content with each other so go to go to
daily wire comm slash subscribe and join
today ok for our daily cancellation the
National Museum of african-american
history and culture is in line to be
canceled today I know that in times like
these it may seem like a provocative
thing to cancel the African American
History Museum but I have good reason on
their website there's an article telling
us how to talk about race because
apparently there's a shortage of
articles explaining how to talk about
race there's only 15 published today I
guess the African American History
Museum thought we need to add a
sixteenth and so they did but in that
article there's a graphic and here is
the graphic and this is what's getting
them canceled this is what did it the
graphic err you look at let's read
through it together
it says aspects and assumptions of
whiteness and white culture in the
United States
okay explains white culture or whiteness
refers to the ways white people and
their traditions attitudes and ways of
life have been normalized over time and
are now considered standard practices in
the United States and since white people
still hold most of the institutional
power in America we have all
internalized some aspects of white
culture including people of color and
that goes through and talks about the
aspects of white culture rugged
individualism the individuals the
primary units self-reliance independence
and autonomy highly valued
the nuclear family father mother two and
a half children is the ideal social unit
husband is breadwinner head of household
children should have their own rooms so
some of this is just children should
have that how is that a white thing my
kids don't have their own rooms I didn't
have my own room this okay you say it's
a white thing I you have to be a lot
more specific than that it's it's
definitely not an Irish Catholic thing I
can tell you that emphasis on scientific
method is white objective objective
rational linear thinking is the domain
of whiteness cause-and-effect
relationships is is white
cause-and-effect
you know I thought that was just a
fundamental aspect of physical reality
apparently not
squares are only square in white culture
- I don't know if you do that squares in
every other culture triangles or squares
so history based on northern European
immigrants experience the United States
okay that one makes a little bit more
sense Protestant work ethic hard work is
the key to success work before play
future orientation delayed gratification
planned for the future time time is is
is owned by white people what else we
miss a status power and authority
respect for authority Christianity how
how Christianity is a white thing you
know that that also beats main
Christianity began in the Middle East
Christianity is thriving more in
non-white countries than it is in white
countries holidays based on white
history male leaders okay justice intent
counts so in only from a white
perspective should we should we talk
should we discuss intent when talking
about crimes competition wintered all
cost action orientation decision
decision-making okay so there we have
there's some of the things that are
that our hallmark hallmarks of Michael's
just to recap hallmarks of white culture
says them you says the African American
History Museum or among other things
self-reliance hard work family
objectivity science politeness respect
cause-and-effect relationships delayed
gratification and time itself these are
all white things couple of strange
things about this speaking of being
counterproductive first of course these
are all very good things so I am NOT as
a white person insulted by a means by
any of this I guess we're supposed to be
suspicious of these things or have a
negative view of them but they are all
they are all they're mostly very good so
this really amounts to an almost
unbelievably racist attack on all other
races on planet Earth because it
essentially claims that none of them are
hard-working objective or polite or at
least at least if they are those things
it's only because they are borrowing
from or being influenced by or even
maybe we would say appropriating white
culture so we see again this very
strange overlap which actually is not so
strange when you and you really get into
and think about it but there's an
overlap between white supremacism and
SJW woke nests the two sides speak
almost in tandem echoing each other and
then also the other part of this notice
how this is all describing white culture
white culture but but wait a second not
only white culture but it says you know
white traditions white everything so
according to this white people have a
culture we have traditions we have
identity okay but wait a second have we
not been told time and again that white
people don't have a culture that there
is no white culture yes that's not my
imagination we have been told that the
lack of white culture is the reason why
for example we're supposed to capitalize
black now but not white and the reason
that we're given if we're given any
reason at all
is that you know black is in reference
to a very specific group of people
specific culture so you capitalize it
like you would capitalize Jew you know
or Chinese but white is not why it is
not a culture it's not a specific group
it's not an identity that's that's what
we're told and it's also why I think
most importantly it's also why we are
told that it is racist for a white
person to be proud of their race for a
white person to say I am proud of being
white or I'm proud of my whiteness or
whatever that is racist but it's not
racist
we're told for any other race to say
that any other race can say that and
it's perfectly fine exact not just fine
it's it's laudable it's something to
celebrate we they should be proud of it
white people aren't supposed to be proud
of their race again the reason that
we're given for that if you've ever
asked the reason is that white white is
not a culture it's not an identity and
so there's nothing to be proud of so if
you say that you're proud of being white
what you really mean
says this version is is just that you
mean to express sort of a negative view
of other races that's so it's where as a
black person saying I'm proud of being
black I'm proud of my blackness that's a
that's a positive statement about their
black identity for a white person to say
it because white people lack culture and
identity it's it's it's it's now a
negative statement about other races
that's the explanation but now we're
being told that white is a culture and
not only is it a culture but it's a
culture with with according to this many
many very positive aspects of everything
I just read is my - my minor most of the
things that they list here very very
good so if that really is white culture
then who wouldn't be proud of that if
white people according to this have
ownership somehow or have have invented
or have some sort of unique
and ship with respecting Authority being
polite valuing family delaying
gratification working hard and of course
we can be proud of that so which is it
do we have a culture or not well the
answer is this here's the answer because
it all gets very confusing and you're
wondering what's going on the answer is
if you're white you have a culture and
an identity when the left needs you to
have one for political and ideological
reasons and you don't have it when they
need you not to have one
so it changes by the day by the hour by
the minute
it can change from sentence to sentence
when you're listening to a leftist speak
that's the answer it's just it's
entirely up to them and it's whatever
they happen to need in the moment and
you exist and not just as a white person
but as all people you exist to to follow
their orders and obey them and to fit
into whatever box they put you in and I
said as I said this does not just apply
to white people this is this in fact it
specially applies to minorities and any
minority who ventures outside of the box
that has been assigned to them by the
left and express his views they're not
supposed to express according to the
left has learned how they get treated
which is even worse than the dreaded you
know heterosexual cisgendered white
mangastream so that's the answer that's
it the arbitrariness is the point
because we are meant to follow along and
be obedient and go with the program and
follow the script it is not to reason
why it is but to do and die that's it
fall to follow do it do as you're told
is the message from the left and from
the elites in in our culture in media
academia government that's what they
want you to know and because of all that
this cancellation has been doled out and
we'll leave it there Thanks
everybody for watching thanks for
listening have a great day Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]